we have new eyewitness accounts of the
deadly ambush of American troops in
Nazaire four American soldiers were
killed last month by Isis linked
militants near the village of tango
tango CBS News traveled to the remote
side of the ambush and spoke to the
people who actually saw the attack
Debora patta is engineer in Nazir's
capital that's Yummie with what she
learned there
Deborah good morning good morning we now
know that US and Nigerian troops were on
a reconnaissance mission but at some
point they Aldus change that meant they
had to stay overnight in dangerous
territory that could have alerted
extremists to where they were after
spending the night in treacherous
terrain the US and Nigerian troops
stopped for supplies at the village of
Tongo Tongo on their way out of the area
it was here that they were lured into a
trap three or four armed men appeared on
motorcycles and started shooting
initially a few Isis fighters drew the
troops to this spot they burnt down that
school and then push them in this
direction to where the ambush actually
took place over there village elder adam
abu bakr witnessed the ambush and said
he saw at least 60 attackers armed with
machine guns and rocket-propelled
grenades the fighting lasted over two
hours when it was over he told us he saw
the bodies of three American soldiers
two of the bodies were in the vehicle
and another on the ground he said they'd
been stripped of their uniforms but it
would be two days before children from
the village discovered the fourth body
of Sergeant Lee David Johnson about half
a mile away
the village chief alerted the military
that they'd found Johnson
shortly after this he was arrested by
them on suspicion of colluding with the
terrorists his distraught mother insists
this is not true it's still not clear
how Johnson got separated from the rest
this Nigerian soldier would only talk if
we concealed his identity Johnson had
been stripped of his uniform he told us
his hands were tied and they'd shot him
in the head the Pentagon would not
comment
we're getting more pieces of the puzzle
but it's still unclear why the US
mission was extended overnight in an
area where more than a dozen extremist
groups are operating Vlad Debora patta
Indy share thank you